okay let's talk to a few more people
we're taking calls via the david pakman
show discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord make sure to become a uh
subscriber to the discord it's free i'm
selling you nothing other than a good
time
let's talk to uh why don't we talk to
maria from ohio maria you're on the air
hello hello hi um
i have one one comment and one question
generally um
my comment is i just really wanted to
say
um i appreciate uh lately i've been
noticing
you're you're making an effort not to
stigmatize
mental illness um like the caller
yesterday and
i've noticed i mean uh just just
you know things that you how you treat
uh
the the general i think urges for people
to just
ridicule people who are of the other
side who are clearly mentally ill or
maybe
not clearly but you know suspected and i
just
i really appreciate that you're making
an effort to
to not further stigmatize mental illness
um my pleasure
that's brad thank you um and then my
question is just
if you have any tips for talking with
the older generation about fixing this
policing issue uh because i have a hard
time talking with my parents about it
they're
they're in their 70s and they just their
general assumption is like to assume
that you know they need the the military
militarized gear and everything and need
all of this
stuff that clear it's clearly not proper
to fund
that way you know well i think i would
probe and say why do you think
police departments should be militarized
and they'll have some answer and then
say
okay can you give me some examples of
situations
where police being more militarized
helped
there really aren't many i mean it you
know it put
make them just sort of examine how they
came to these conclusions
because what where what what type of pla
were what what part of the world do they
live in ohio maria
yeah yeah we're from ohio yeah i mean in
wherever they live in ohio
are there examples of when police being
more militarized help to resolve a
situation that they can think of
and if there aren't any examples they
can think of then say okay well what
about in the entire state of ohio
or what about in the entire region tell
me exactly how we've been bet we've
benefited
from police being more militarized and
then if you can get them to realize
it actually hasn't really done much for
anybody then
you could go to the next step of look at
the money that's being spent there
aside there's also a fiscal issue which
may appeal to them in some way i don't
know
yeah thank you yeah i i try and
talk to them a little bit about it like
you should kind of be upset that your
tax dollars are being used this way
right kind of there are much better
places for them to be used
you know there's debate over whether we
on the left
should use right wing framings
to talk to people who are on the right
some people say you should some people
say you shouldn't
but it seems that the fiscal thing is at
least worth trying
yeah yeah oh thank you all right maria
thank you maria from ohio
great to hear from you let's try uh
let's go elsewhere
let's go to oh you know who we should go
to we we have to figure out what's going
on
let's go to noog wrangler from
california
noog you're on the air
new grongler you were on the air if you
want to unmute oh yes
hello david for some reason uh it didn't
unmute
sounds like user error i don't know yes
it must be not too many nugs or
something
what can i do for you uh well before i
ask
my question i wanted to clarify
that according to a post on your
subreddit
pad callers use speakerphone
would you prefer i use speakerphone no
no thank you
okay okay good well if that post is
wrong
and it claims that bad callers preface
their question with the long monologue
let me begin with mine uh-oh so it all
started
when okay never mind i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do that um
written down and it's coming now please
okay so
do people that are unhappy with the
employer employee structure of
capitalism
that would rather be in a worker
cooperative
that just isn't there yet now what
message can we offer as progressives
other than maybe like i don't know cope
and weight
well i guess it's not cope and weight
it's
starter worker cooperative right i mean
it seems that the quickest way to be
part of a worker cooperative
rather than waiting around is to to get
involved in one and
and start one i don't know what advice i
would have yeah
yeah sorry for the question i also was
going to say other than you know start a
co-op because it takes a lot of money
so you're saying man if people want more
worker co-ops other than waiting
for it to become more prevalent coping
with the fact that it's not
and other than starting one themselves
what can they do
yeah i maybe i didn't um you know
formulate that question well
no no it's fine i mean i maybe call your
elected officials and encourage them to
i don't know pass maybe preferential
tracks a tax
treatment for worker co-ops maybe
there's something there uh
that could maybe you know look at if you
want to operate at the city or town
level
look at maybe grants for worker co-ops
on rent subsidies or something like i
don't know any you know
anything that would make it more
appealing i guess for a company to be
structured that way
actually calling an elected rep sounds
like a good idea yeah
okay well uh yeah thanks thanks for
taking my call all right
there it is noog wrangler with a
very specific question which we love
which we love